to understand the classified nature of  this mission and the legal  non-disclosure agreements that you sign  which prohibit you from ever discussing  this project to anyone outside this room  I understand and you understand the full  nature of this program yes I'm fully  aware  this is light and cosmic matter entering  and leaving  so what we're potentially looking at  here is the wormhole  and we believe that this activity  occurred at the same time as the strange  dark orbs that have been appearing in  our skies talking about probably one of  the most important things that has  happened in space exploration I think we  need to move forward on that I think you  need get informed now  we could be looking at the first contact  with intelligent life  the post ability of something else out  there for us it changes everything it's  that simple motion which drives the  human 2.0 project  [Music]  [Applause]  we could not have been more wrong about  all of this  you  you